[Music]
give me something in that movie yeah
i'll play someone in the crowd well you
can do you can yeah you can play the
same role you did in game of thrones
which was what gay guy number five
remember like way back i'm [ __ ] gay
i'm [ __ ] gay no that was that it was
from that was it game with does that
what you're joking about
you were auditioning for something yeah
okay it was like you know your role as
gay guy number three yeah yeah right
yeah but there's a lot more and action
i'm [ __ ] gay that's not in the cut
it's not in the script
you just said i play a gay guy so what
else am i how am i supposed to
i only have like i only have like two
seconds of screen time how am i supposed
to illustrate that um
damn that's so funny just a camera
panning over a group of extras you're
just going wild in that [ __ ] like i'm
gay i'm gay sign i'm gay
did did somebody give him a sign props
was that
there's no sign in this no he brought
that himself
i thought it would help can we fly that
out of there
you just pull your shirt up it's like a
temp tattoo
that lasts for like five days it's like
hannah why are you doing this
well because i'm gay i play a gay guy it
doesn't say that
you're just an extra i know but i
thought it would give it a little bit of
like you know some some layers for me to
be a gay guy
i mean look at this guy next time he
looks so straight he's obviously
straight i mean and this girl right here
is straight as a [ __ ] arrow yeah
let's mix it
up we can't all be straight that's not
real
so i should be yeah there's there's
definitely like there how many people
are in this like these stands right here
like nine
the the stats are like one and three
exactly so there's another one here
someone here probably has cancer
someone here probably has a like their
mother battled lymphoma yeah
some extra was like hey what the [ __ ]
dude it's like c
c that's a stat so i should be gay
stat is one and three so they're like
okay you can be a just don't do anything
don't say anything
over your [ __ ] kissing some guys
[Laughter]
zoom in zoom in zoom in zoom in
jack's like yo what the [ __ ] like jack
step out the way
just get this right here this is
powerful this is powerful what's going
on this is why i got into this business
it just
yeah just just making like crazy
[ __ ] goes on way too long like two
minutes
the director's like this is the best
part about working digital
you know we used to work on film we have
to cut something like this we can just
keep going
we can just keep going
and cut wow wow wow
you just come out you're like see i told
you i told you it works right
wow
yeah so that's how you have to make it
in hollywood guys you got to really
you know push it you got to show people
your range
that was one of the things that like
about that whole process and we talked
about this before right the fact that
like in hollywood to make it as a
traditional actor is brutal
your life your career is in the hands of
like 500 people you who you don't even
know you never see them
the fact that i got through every
creative person that was involved in
that project literally the the writer
the creator everyone is sitting in that
room both the leads they all like me and
some [ __ ] suits
in an office were like
nah it is not right yes d cam it's like
no i was so close just let me through
yeah
oh this is your little dream right here
this is your little dream
ate that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah
damn
now i'm just thinking about extras
[ __ ] and by the way no offense to the
suits you know if i go up for someone
else
i didn't mean suits in a bad way i
didn't mean that in a derogatory sense i
didn't i just meant like the suit looks
nice is that a tom fortsu
you guys i love it it looks great on you
and it's fit it's tailored too you got
to put an asterisk in the word suits
when you type it online
yeah it's a slur yeah what
what what is
suits yeah that's a slur yeah that's not
a slur that's what i'm saying i meant it
in like a positive way
no it's like it's a good way
like you look good you guys are good
you're going to a black tie event or
something yeah
yeah literally jane you look like james
bond they're just they're just looking
at
your perspective roles and just
following them up right now as you say
this
we're just some suits huh oh we'll show
you a suit no i'm sure you guys are
creative too
some cool [ __ ] probably
sorry i'm just thinking of more extras
just like [ __ ] up the vibe like
just like playing an extra like i don't
know like a school assembly and you just
start like pulling open the middle of
your button-up shirt and there's a
superman s yeah yeah cut
what the [ __ ] are you doing well i mean
i thought it would be cool if i was
superman
what this movie's [ __ ] boring
wouldn't it be cool if like someone in
the class was superman
i mean it would but we don't have the
rights to superman
oh okay
stupendous man then
we could be just like a derivation of
superman
always showing up in different scenes
like just putting on the spiderman yeah
stop stop cut
how does he keep getting these where
does he get these we don't have the
rights for that
it's a dark ass scene they pan over just
batman just in the darkness
in the corner the dark hey
you're just in the corner peas and
carrots
peas and carrots
because that's what they tell extras to
say to look like they're talking carrots
you